so good morning or almost good lunchtime
people grabbed a snack on the way so we
weren't starving well you're here plus
I'm gonna make you do some exercise
while we're here all right so um hello
my name is Julie Lerman and I'm gonna
talk somewhat about DDD but a lot about
sharing what you've learned and this was
specific to DDD but hopefully some of
these ideas you can carry on to other
things that you're sharing and I really
like the fact that I'm doing this after
David Neil's keynote because a lot of
what he talked about also was sharing
sharing what you've learned so this is
going to be though focused on domain
driven design who here is actually doing
some kind of work where you're involved
with DDD or or wishes you could like
know this cool stuff about DDD I hope
other people will want to do that with
me on my team so this this talk has a
pretty funny origin some of you may be
aware that I also do a lot of work with
Microsoft's ORM object relational mapper
which is called entity framework so it's
very data focused right this is a data
persistence tool and I also do a lot of
work with DDD and I do a lot about
bringing the two together which to some
people may seem pretty antithetical as a
matter of fact I was at a DDD conference
DDD Europe a few years ago and I had
done a workshop on looking at where
entity framework or was at with respect
to being able to map to a map to your
database like if you design things
really nicely from the perspective of
domain driven design
tactical approaches how is ddd doing
with respect to mapping things directly
into the database and so after I did
that there was somebody who was saying
to me well you know you really shouldn't
be showing people about domain driven
design this way because you know you're
not showing them the whole end-to-end
and they're not going to learn it right
and they're gonna misuse it and abuse it
and so I wrote this tweet afterwards and
I use this word in my tweet about the
DDD purists and some few people came up
to me they were not happy that I used
this word and I was actually thankful I
hadn't used the word zealot which might
have brought yet a more dramatic
response to that anyway so I actually I
thought I thought about this for a few
minutes and went directly to another
person who runs a DDD conference in
Berlin Kandinsky or Kandinsky DDD in the
middle get it and said this would be
such a great keynote because it's kind
of controversial so I undo it as a
keynote there but I did it as a talk and
I did it as a keynote at a DDD
conference in London a couple of weeks
ago and I'm happy to be able to continue
sharing this message so you know so what
is it about this word purists and and
what is it that I wanted to talk about
and you know so the title of the talk is
you know pragmatic or principled and I
really wanted to start thinking about
that word what was it that made me want
to say purist right what was it that
almost made me want to say but kept it
to myself the word zealot right and
really I think when people are the
people who are thinking in those terms
that reaction I got it's not that
they're purists or zealots it's really
that they're really focused on the
principles of domain driven design and
want to make sure that
when they're expressing DDD to other
people that people understand the
principles so so perhaps that is a
better word and with that thinking about
the term principle I wondered you know
can we still be pragmatic and and
continue to be principled at the same
time so pragmatic to me it's more
practical right can we be more practical
in the way that we're helping other
people learn about domain-driven design
and help other people get excited about
it about using some of these practices
in DDD whether it's you know from the
planning part or building aggregates or
things like that you know can we have a
pragmatic approach make sure people
understand the principles but still help
other people get on board or give
ourselves as David was talking about
this morning give ourselves a bit of a
break right to say look I understand
some things about DDD and that's great
and I can use them and really benefit
from them and then I'll learn more
things right I'll grow my knowledge of
DDD and my expertise and be able to take
advantage of and benefit from other
things so I think one of the things that
was driving me to that word purist which
has quite a negative connotation was I
felt like and I actually think about
this with a lot of technologies that the
peep that when we focus on the
terminology and these rules right I mean
they yes principles but when really
really focus on rules I think it shuts a
lot of people out I was at a talk that
Eric Evans did a few years ago
I'm DDD's been you know the book of the
blue book that Eric wrote 2003 so it's
been 14 16 years my math skills just
flew out the window with my jet lag it's
been 16 years so he
did this talk a few years ago and he was
saying you know it's been a lot of years
that DDD's been around how come more
people aren't using it and using it or
benefiting from it and I really thought
that I think that it's these rules in
these definitions and I think that a lot
of people get overwhelmed by the
largeness of domain-driven design and
all the rules and just don't feel
confident even doing any of it or even
hearing people say you know DDD like if
you're oh you're not doing this you
can't say you're doing ddd or you know
you're not doing ddd
and it really shuts people out so this
is something I've thought about a lot
and what's kind of funny in the
background this is like a rant I had
written it's just text you have to read
it but it was like you know all the
things I would I would be saying about
that because I think about this a lot
and enabling people I was working with a
client last month they had brought me in
because this was happening at their in
on their teams people they they were
using the domain driven design approach
and trying to get all their scrum teams
on board with it and people were saying
the developers especially I am so sick
of hearing about DDD I don't talk to me
about it anymore just just let me do my
work
right and so here was a problem because
the architect and some other people had
really worked hard to define things in a
way using this great guidance from
domain driven design and they were
having a hard time getting especially
the coding teams to kind of go along
with that so you know so how does this
happen so what I want to do is start
with remember I gave a hint already
we're going to do a little something
physical I want to start with a little
bit of an exercise and it means pairing
up and I learned about this from a woman
named Jess Eastern host she
is an improv she does improv but she
uses improv to help development teams
work with each other she uses it in
hospitals to help doctors better
understand patient experience and you
know she uses it for all kinds of things
and she did something like this at a
conference I was at recently and gave me
permission to you know share it but I've
put my own twist on it to try to help
you step back a little bit and
understand perhaps what it might be like
to somebody who's never used DDD before
when you're like oh we have to use
aggregates we have to use the ubiquitous
language and we have to use value
objects and you know all all of the
terms so what we're gonna do well I just
say what you're gonna do is find a
partner I would say you know maybe
somebody who's sitting next to you or
behind you or in front of you and we're
gonna do something called a mirror game
so hey I just got 700 people in London
to do this so I wonder how it's gonna
work and skin and Naevia everybody's so
withdrawn but we're gonna do it so begin
by standing up everybody stand up you
can do it I also got them to do it first
thing in the morning and just fine you
know the person closest to you what
you're gonna do is a mirror game and the
mirror game is you're gonna draw one
person you're gonna switch so each
person will do this so one person is
going to draw the numbers 2 4 6 8 and 10
and the other person will mirror them
light you draw at an air so you know and
four and six and eight and ten so you do
that and then when you finish doing that
switch and the other person does the
drawing and the other person is the
mirror and let's not spend 20 minutes
doing this so let's just go go ahead and
do it find a partner and draw it or not
and draw 2 4 6 8 and 10
I'm not quite as easy as you thought is
that oh do it you can do it at the same
time like you're in front of a mirror
good job guys I saw that high five all
right who's got five-year-olds you know
what this is right
this is what this is what my my friend
is a teacher does with her class like
all the kids start raising their hands
like it's time to quiet down uh-oh the
last two guys all right so what was the
hardest one to emulate Tamir eight four
four yeah four and eight I think the
problem with eight is people draw at
different ways right and you don't know
what how the other person's style of
drawing and eight is but a four is just
all kinds of confusion what what was the
easiest number do you think the one the
one in ten right I think that's well
that's what I was hoping you say and I
think that's what I heard the one in ten
so you know imagine if you're learning
to do this wouldn't you want to start
with that one and like oh this works
great you have all kinds of confidence
and then you can then move on to another
one right but you get the one down right
and you can actually have that
confidence and be successful and maybe
even benefit from it because you can use
ones in all kinds of places right and
then you know okay let's try let's try
to next right and you can can start
working working on the two and then you
get some benefits out of that so drawing
that back to domain-driven design my
whole way of my own way of learning
things and my way of sharing things with
people is just like that just like let's
just start with one and we'll use that
don't worry about the rest of it don't
worry about it don't worry about four
don't even worry about that one is part
of ten right let's just use one we'll
just use that for a while we can do some
things with it you know it's all good
and then we can add another one and then
build our expertise and build up our
capabilities
and then you know and then you start
building this rich set of capabilities
with that so bringing again bringing
that back to domain driven design then
the question I ask myself is so where
would you start
what's the number what's that one right
and sometimes this really depends on if
I'm working with a team or if you're
just work you know working with just
somebody on your team or you know
however it is that you might be sharing
I think from me
perhaps the most important thing is for
if once you get to the point where
you're saying okay we're talking about
domain driven design is the core are the
core principles the most important
things to learn first right just all
those principles you know principles
being principled is that pragmatic right
so a lot of this is asking you know
asking questions not necess this is not
necessarily the answer but a lot of
people do try to start with those core
principles and sometimes that's already
too much if you've seen the mind map of
domain driven design you know now I look
at it and I understand this but this is
overwhelming right and sometimes this is
the first thing and and telling people
you know okay we need to learn all of
these things at once that's enough to
make me run away right because I don't
even know where to start so as somebody
who has some familiarity with DDD you
know fine find you can use your your
your own perspective to an experience to
figure out if you're sharing it where
might be a good place to start with the
person you're sharing it with right
you've got some context there that might
help but really I don't think saying all
right now we're going to do them at a
domain driven design
I found not by experience because again
it's not my instinctive way of going
about it
but a lot of people do they say okay
we're gonna learn domain driven design
and that again
for some people it's enough to make them
like already be blocking right and they
start not they're already that got that
plugs in their ears and they're not
going to be able to focus because it's
too much right or even starting you know
let's just dive into all these this
terminology right that may not mean
aggregate root and value objects that
won't mean something to a lot of people
so saying we're gonna learn aggregate
roots and we're going to learn value
objects again could be something that
really turns people off so what works
that I found what works for me when I'm
sharing is not to tell somebody what
we're going to be teaching them but just
to do it right just to jump in and do it
so I do and I do this a lot with clients
also where we'll just start doing the
work but I won't say you know maybe
we'll start looking for bounded contexts
but I won't tell them that we're looking
for bounded context we're just doing
some work on their domain I won't even
use the word domain right I'll just say
you know what what problems are you're
trying to solve let's just take a look
so I'll steer them towards what a
bounded context is maybe and then
eventually I will tell them by the way
DDD all right this is called a bounded
context but I make sure they understand
the concept of what it is that they've
done what we're looking at before we
drill you know before I introduce that
terminology I added this in because I
also found this was interesting
perspective I was at actually it was
that same DD Kandinsky conference in
Berlin Michel feathers was speaking a
little before me and he said something
that I thought was really interesting
that led led me to this idea because he
was talking about turning language and
structure inside
he wasn't talking specifically about
domain-driven design but in
domain-driven design one of the paths is
you do something called strategic design
and you come up with what's referred to
as the ubiquitous language you so you
come up with this language of how to
talk about the domain you're working in
and then from that language that's where
we start designing our architecture and
designing our you know I'm going to use
the terms designing our aggregate routes
and designing our entities and designing
our aggregates right so it starts with
the language and then goes to the
structure so that's like the classical
principled path of going through DDD
right and but I actually find it works a
lot when I'm starting with structure I'm
stroking already with people who have
code written they've already been doing
architecture they've already actually
got an application that they're working
on code that they've already written so
we've already got the structure but they
don't have the language yet which is
fine by me because I can actually help
them see what that language is from the
structure that already exists right so
and this is another reason that I had
that early criticism because that that I
showed at the beginning where I had
talked about the purist because I was
working with existing code classes that
already defined aggregates that were
already defined nicely just a fine
domain right and that you know so we
started with that and then worked on DDD
ideas after that instead of starting
with it you know all the strategic
design and understanding and analyzing
the problems you're trying to solve and
then working the other way so I find a
lot of times that if we have the
structure already if we have an
understanding of our domain if we
already have code that's written in
objects and classes
well classes and
and etc I can help people understand DDD
starting with something that already
exists that they already have a good
comprehension of and we can grow it out
of there
somebody called out something funny I
hadn't realized somehow there seems to
be a history of people in DDD using this
analogy of a garden and I had come up to
this on my own which says I think a lot
because it may be it just means it is
the perfect analogy but I feel like you
know this this path of learning whether
it's my own learning or my sharing with
other people really is like gardening in
a way but you can start out with just
you know just this right instead of
saying okay we're gonna like do a garden
now right but you can start with this
and evolve it and evolve it and evolve
it and eventually get to this even if
you start with the understanding that
someday this is what we want to get to
don't worry about that now let's just
you know work on these little things
first and and eventually we'll get to
the other but don't stress out about how
you're gonna get to this big big big
garden I had known this story in the
back of my head I couldn't figure it out
I I couldn't put my finger on it before
I did the this as a keynote in London
would have been perfect because
Bletchley Park where they did the code
breaking in World War two Alan Turing
and all of those people and then I went
to Bletchley Park after I did after that
conference and I was reminded of what
this story was Mike problem so I thought
this is a really good example of where I
think I said okay is that better I mean
I moved it too far away from my face but
it was a good idea right you don't want
to hear me
coughing this was such a cool story so
when when they were getting these
messages the decrypted messages that the
Germans had encrypted with ass Enigma
machine it's a picture of an Enigma
machine they were getting these messages
and if they would just sit and just work
really hard trying to figure out you
know every day because that what they
were using to they were encoding the
Enigma machine differently every single
day right so every day the people who
are trying to decode we're starting from
scratch and then one day somebody went
wait a minute every single day it starts
with a weather report every day it
starts with a weather report right so
they were able to say we know that
whatever is that this little thing of
the beginning that's going to be the
weather report and they used that as
their path in to be able to you know
understand and identify what that day's
encryption was so that they can go and
decrypt the rest of the message so I
like that as a really cool analogy again
I would have been so great to use that
in London because it's their it's their
history but I think that's a really cool
analogy to you know being able to start
with something small that you can really
manage and it also aligns so much with
one of the most important concepts of
domain driven design which is breaking
big problems down into small solvable
problems right that's what these bounded
contexts are right just take one problem
and completely ignore all the rest of it
and just focus on this one thing right
and then you can solve that that good
that's like the one in in you know if
you just focused on the ones like yay
we've got week I just we've we've got
something we can hold on to this just
made me think of something really funny
my dad who just turned 85 on Sunday like
literally I just
was thinking just like this problem I
had you turn 85 in Sunday my mom passed
away about four years ago boo
my dad never learned to cook he was
spoiled guy growing up his mom always
cooked my mom always cooked he did the
he balance the checkbook my mom did not
know how to balance a checkbook and my
dad we've been every time my any of my
siblings and I go home to visit him we
cook and cook and cook and free stuff
and put it in the freezer and he brings
it out last I was there a year ago I
tried to teach him about actually eating
vegetables because he does not Eve edge
Tibbles we brought bought a bag of
frozen broccoli and put it in the
freezer I'm like dad this real easy you
can just pour it in to some boiling
water and boy you know cook it and
you'll have broccoli and it was there
for a year so I was there a couple of
weeks ago and tried again there it was
still the year old bag of broccoli but
it was frozen so it was okay and I
encouraged him to try it the other day
he I talked to him I said so you know
any luck with the broccoli cuz you know
man cannot live on frozen meatloaf alone
and he said yeah I actually almost
finished it up I finally did it and I
realize how easy it was right now I'm
like oh no he can't now he's like got
this expertise and cooking frozen
broccoli he might now he can get frozen
corn he can get frozen string beans
right he's got this he got something he
nailed down he's eating he's getting his
nourishment right and now he's gonna
kind of grow his garden so a lot of this
then that that bagged broccoli right
this is kind of like the bounded context
right taking one problem that you can
kind of disconnect from all the other
problems you're trying to solve in your
software and focus on that bounded
context is the most important concept in
domain-driven design everything revolves
around that and as a matter of fact I
think it was here
maybe on this very stage Eric did a talk
last that last time I was at NDC he said
if I were to write the book over again I
would start by teaching bounded context
because it is the probably the most core
important concept for people to
understand in ddd not only is it the
most important thing it is the most
misunderstood thing and I am living
proof of that as somebody who came from
an ORM I know of one person in this room
who is quite the entity framework guru
he's written a few books on EF core and
he's doing talks tomorrow talk tomorrow
on any framework as anybody else here
use entity framework and anybody you
weren't you don't come here hoping I
would talk about any framer by the way
right you go to John's talk so when any
framework first came out what it taught
us to do was point to our existing
legacy database with its 700 tables and
65,000 foreign key constraints built
into it point to it and build a model
from that and then everything we did was
from that big huge model does anybody
remember doing that is anybody using EF
for all that time I remember doing that
and I knew it just was not right right
it just created so much problems always
working on that one big model and the
first time I started learning about DDD
it did kind of come in to come in
bounded context wasn't the first thing I
learned about DDD my introduction into
it but it was quickly thereafter and I
didn't really understand bounded context
the way I understood stand it now
but what I understood was it about this
idea of taking big things and breaking
them down into smaller problems subsets
of the problem and then just focusing on
that and I used that idea it wasn't
really truly bounded context but I used
that just that kernel from the full
bounded context idea
to help me solve that problem that was
really really knowing at me about those
gigantic models datum entity data models
that we were working with and so I start
that was that was how I started kind of
down my path of domain-driven design
somebody quickly made sure I understood
that that wasn't truly a bounded context
right because that's important because
if I'm saying Oh breaking a data model
up into small data models that are
easier to you know work with just this
one here and this one there make sure
that I didn't say and that is what a DDD
bounded context is because it's really
going to mislead people so I was I was
helped in that way and that was you know
not in a critical way too which is so
great the DDD community is so wonderful
that you know they were just helping me
because they saw I was starting to bring
some DDD ideas to a new audience so they
were helping me communicate it this just
I love this
an analogy actually it comes from Eric's
original book he is the idea of cells
right if you think about the bounded
context he is the idea that a cell
really knows only about itself it
doesn't know anything about what's going
on in other cells right and it doesn't
leak things out to other cells we'd all
be pretty sick if it did that and then
we have the membranes around each cell
they're responsible for what information
passes through from one cell to another
so it's that it's that boundary right
that's so each cell is really really
tightly bound it but the membrane so you
don't think of the membrane as the cell
itself the membrane is really how
communication happens from one cell to
another so I really learned about
boundaries before I understood the
bounded context and I used that I
realized how powerful it was for me
right even though I didn't know the
definition of a bounded context right
and nobody nobody thank goodness was
whipping me for you know saying well
that's not really a bounded context
you're not doing it right
right I was already benefiting from this
idea by using just a part of it a hugely
benefiting from it and that's really key
to my message here that you can truly
benefit from pieces even if you don't
have the whole thing already right so
boundaries was really important so I
think I'm a really good example of this
path to learning DDD you know I'm
speakin EVD conferences I write about it
a lot I have a reputation as being you
know pretty well-versed with
domain-driven design I do consulting and
coaching for clients with it
but you know I did have that that very
different path to learning it than the
classical path I did not sit down and
read Eric's book the Blue Book from end
to end although I have to say I started
I did start reading the book from the
beginning but I got a little distracted
because the reason I had picked the book
up was not because I'm going to learn
DDD but I was writing my very first my
very first tech book that was an and any
framework book and I'd heard an
interview that Jimmy Nielsen did and
they were talking oh they were really
interviewing about the big link to
sequel and entity framework problem at
Microsoft's anybody remember that they
both came up with two different two
different teams and Microsoft came up
with two different ORM s at the same
time because they hadn't been
communicating with each other so they
were asking him about that but at the
end they asked him a question they asked
everybody what's your favorite book and
he said oh domain-driven design it reads
like poetry and here I was starting my
very first book and I was like whoa
poetry I wonder with that you know what
does that like in a tech book and that's
why I picked the book up and immediately
when I started reading it I have that
sense or Eric's very philosophical
but also he was talking about the
importance of client collaboration when
you're doing you know in in the idea of
domain-driven design as you're doing
this kind of design the domain experts
your clients they're key to everything
and how important it is to be working
with them and partnering with them not
just like you know they don't know
anything about programming anyway
that's actually what drew me mostly into
DDD like that was my first hint because
that's something I'd always loved with
my own clients and I thought here's
somebody now I'm not he's a brilliant
man I'm not saying I have his genius but
I just thought you know here's here's
somebody who thinks a lot in the same
way as I do and respects people in the
same way as I do and that was actually
how I I came into it I also have felt
for many years especially in the dotnet
space that I've been kind of like a
canary in the coal mine right so it's
like if I can learn this other people
can learn this but also I think my path
to learning is a good like like this
says you know an exhibit of how people
can move into DDD so I'm just going to
talk a little bit about literally my
path into domain driven design and I'm
wondering if this aligns with anybody
else's those of you who are already kind
of interested in it or actually being
implementing some of some of the
guidance from DDD and I really think of
it as guidance right I'm not like oh
these are the rules right it's all to me
it's all its guidance and these are
great ideas and there's a lot of
heuristics around the guidance that you
know how things are working and that
it's proven but also you know taking
into account the fact that we're all
bringing our intelligence and our
experience and our expertise to the
table also so take that guidance and
kind of integrate it with all those
other things you're bringing
so I did kind of start with with that
domain focus a client collaboration
really understanding what the problems
are that the business is trying to solve
and you know it is to me it is problems
and solutions right we're building
software solutions so we must be solving
problems I when I was working with a
client somebody said and I might be not
quoting him exactly right but he said
something like the domain is the problem
you're trying to solve and the bounded
context is the solution which I thought
was really interesting anyway so I was
really really focused on the domain and
then the first thing from there was that
I really looked at how I can leverage
this concept of boundaries again not the
bounded context but this concept of
boundaries and I was really benefitting
from that right out of the box and
sharing that with people again because I
was coming to this from the perspective
of entity framework and ORM I was really
concerned about how things are mapping
to the database and one of the important
things and anybody is doing any work in
microcircuits
you're hearing a lot of the things
aligned as a matter of fact if you're
doing micro services let me at least say
a lot of the problems and patterns laid
out in micro services are problems we've
solved with domain driven design already
for many years so really really good
ideas and guidance to look at in there
and one of them is for each bounded
context you should have a separate a
separate database that's something that
really freaked me out because I've
always been like you know normalized
databases and you know and I've came
from a database focused world I don't
mean that I'm a DBA but I just mean
database development like I started with
FoxPro right oh yeah No
Oh before FoxPro I'm really old I won't
even bother but you know and then
something like access like forms over
data I was really kind of forms over
data so focus on the database so I
thought about that a lot in the idea of
having separate databases was kind of
hard for me to to get over but that was
really the next thing I really focused
on then I started thinking about and
understanding better this concept of
aggregate roots and I'm not going to I'm
not teaching what today what all these
ideas are but so I'm just just letting
you know so if it's not something you're
familiar with don't worry about what
these are just saying that you know it
kind of went into this path aggregates
aggregate root is something you'll see
on that mind map once I understood
aggregate roots then it helped me better
understand what I think is one of the
hardest ideas in domain driven design
and it's not really specifically a DDD
concept but it's critical to DDD which
is value objects right really really
hard concept for me to learn as a matter
of fact I heard probably heard and read
five different descriptions of what
value objects were before over the
course of a year maybe before I finally
went oh oh right you know that that
difference when you're working with
something and you're kind of like yeah I
can do it and it's working in here
I don't really totally get it and it was
that fifth one and it wasn't because
that fifth one was the right one it was
because I was able to now take all five
of those different descriptions and flat
and you know kind of fill out the
picture and it was the five of them
together compared to each other too that
really helped me get there from there I
started having a better understanding of
another thing that is really really
really important in DDD so notice I'm
doing all this stuff
right that are things in DDD and I'm
using it and I'm betting from it and I
still don't even get ubiquitous language
as a matter of fact I got to the point
where when I was reading something if
the phrase ubiquitous language was on
the page more than once I like I wasn't
even absorbing the page I'd be like ah
right because I didn't totally get it
yet but I finally understood ubiquitous
language it's really important for me
and for anybody who's trying to share
what they've learned you know whether
you're helping your team or just other
developers in your community it's really
important to remember how hard it was
for you to first understand something
that's kind of that's one of the reasons
I wanted you to do that mirroring game
so it might be you know awhile since
you've had that feeling maybe you know
since yesterday when some new concept
came to the table right been a long time
and I'm not gonna make a joke about
yesterday's new JavaScript framework not
going there anyway so I finally got
ubiquitous language and it wasn't until
then that I was finally truly able to
understand the most important concept in
domain urban design which is the bounded
context so I came to it on this
circuitous route right but then I
finally had enough comprehension and
experience with these other things that
it was fine I was finally able to truly
understand what about a context is and
the value of a bounded context okay
instead of I have to understand bounded
context first because it's the most
important thing in ddd
and i can't move on until i totally
understand it because it's made up of
all these things not that separate
databases well it's part of what's
important about DD bounded context but
it is made up of boundaries it is made
up of aggregates and aggregate roots and
value objects and the ubiquitous
language drives us to truly understand
what is in your bounded context so I
came to it through the security room yes
I said that right and it was okay right
I was already learning using sharing all
these other great ideas other people
were benefiting from them and nobody was
saying but how can I use you know how
can I use an aggregate if I don't
understand bounded context well you can
right you can you can have an
understanding of a domain entity right
and and an understanding of value
objects and really benefit from them
even if you're not yet using bounded
context and ubiquitous language then I
then I was able to really start
understanding anti the concept of
anti-corruption layers anti-corruption
layers first of all I'm glad the whole
word the whole phrase is there for some
reason I have a block in my brain I can
never remember them people now are used
to the way I say anti-corruption layers
is like this anti-corruption layers
because I have to go through it in my
head first ago ACLs then I have a image
in my head of like the Avengers right
because they're fighting corruption and
crime and then I can remember the phrase
that's just this how it is but it's not
the fact that it took me this the
circuitous route in order to understand
them but I had to really understand my
bounded context before I could
understand anti corruption layers which
is one of the ways where that enables us
to communicate between bounded context
because remember those bounded context
have those membranes around them right
those vary those just you know
unpermitted somehow between bounded
context how are we going to do that so
messaging anti-corruption layers etc are
an important thing so as I was building
up this knowledge but still benefiting
along the way it was also helping me
understand more and more that whole mind
map right like I started really like you
know I've got a lot of this stuff
covered so you know I can't I came into
DDD in a lot of ways this this funny way
because I was looking for something to
help me with this instinctive problem I
had with entity framework which was you
know these huge data models right so I
came to it and and it's such a weird
perspective for a lot of the DDD
community because domain driven design
the whole idea is to not think about
data persistence at all and Here I am
coming from you know focus on data
persistence and how am i using domain
driven design to to help me with that
and it wasn't really helping me persist
data it was really helping me with the
architecture right but it was helping me
understand better how to architect
things because I was architecting them
I was really designing applications to
from the perspective of making the data
persistence better and having DDD just
put that wall right between my
application design and the data
persistence just made me do things even
better right and it really I've been
programming for over 30 years okay
and I think and I was self-taught right
I came up from this database focus this
database driven design really focus I
joked that you know maybe I should just
I would start by designing schemas in
databases right I talked to the client
figure out what they want the first
thing I would think about is how to
design the database and at that point
know now my joke is at that point I
might as well just give them sequel
server management studio as the front
and and and you know go to town so you
know that that was my perspective but it
along the way I was also you know this
this was another challenge for the DDD
community in the way that I had come
into DDD but was sharing it with a whole
new audience that really hadn't thought
about it before because I was talking
about data persistence kind of at the
same time as I was talking about domain
driven design and you know I was just
finding that balance between you know I
had the expertise in though RM and I was
just really looking at if we can design
you know for designing our models our
domain models you know in a beautiful
way based on the things that we learn in
domain driven design
how is entity framework able to persist
that stuff without us having to also
have a extra data model in between so I
was trying to find you know where that
worked and also provide a little balance
right and this is where that word
purists comes in to play right because
some people were not a fan of me finding
balance of saying you know there's this
one beautiful thing I'm doing in my
beautiful domain model and entity
framework doesn't really understand it
right and that's when you're supposed to
say well you know that's why you always
have a data model you never persist
directly to the database and well as far
as I'm concerned the ORM actually does
give us a data model anyway but there's
this point at which I'm I say you know
sometimes that a tiny little thing I can
do to my domain model to just make that
simple for entity framework to do its
job without really perverting my domain
model right I'm not really do it's not
something extreme that I'm doing alright
some people say well you should never do
anything and I was just looking for that
balance and helping people understand
it's okay you know like this this thing
here
this doesn't bother me you know to put
it in like putting foreign key IDs right
as properties in in in my classes right
people fight that but it makes it dirty
I'm like but it makes life so much
simpler and to me DDD it's all about
stress-free programming right so you
know that this this whole entity
framework perspective was a was a
problem for a lot of people so I want to
talk a little bit about some practical
things with respect to what I'm doing
when I'm working with clients so that's
hopefully something that you can take
advantage of as you're sharing it with
people and also just provide a little
bit of advice for if you for helping you
if you're trying to help other people
learn domain driven design or if you're
you know digging into into it yourself
right this isn't all about oh you're
already experts and you're already you
know you want to be evangelists or
something like that
a lot of this is stuff that you can use
either for yourself as you're learning
or sharing with people so what I do when
I most often when I'm working with
clients they are clients that have
legacy applications that they're working
on they've they're either getting ready
to change them and they want to really
make sure that they're not making the
same mistakes not not that there were
mistakes but using modern ideas right
using new ideas to design their software
or sometimes they've already started
doing that project like this the quiet
that I worked with recently that they
were having the problem with the people
who did not want to hear about DDD
anymore they were two years or a year
into the project already so what I do
often again is I don't come in and say
okay we're going to do domain driven
design or okay we're gonna do an
aggregate root now whatever we just
start do you know depending on where
they're at and what problem they're
focused on we just start working
on something you know maybe I'll start
working on what I know is called an
aggregate root but they don't need to
know that I just you know we work on
some design we take a very specific
problem in in their code or their model
that they're thinking about and we kind
of hammer on that or maybe we'll start
looking for some boundaries in a
pre-existing application that they've
written or a data model that they
already have or something I mean I've
gone in with people with those seven
hundred entity admx files that entity
framework data models oh my gosh you
know it's just finding something or
maybe we'll just talk about their
business and try to identify a core
domain something so we do something
we're just doing the work but we're not
defining it and then I'll stand back and
say oh by the way and you know this is
referred to as an aggregate and this
class that is you know doing all this
work and managing all the rules of the
aggregate that's called an aggregate
root so right so they start learning the
terminology but instead of starting with
a terminology which I think I'm because
I know because I do this myself wait I
hear the term and my brain just goes you
know in shutdown mode right because like
I don't know what that means I don't
understand it
and while I'm doing that I'm missing the
lesson missing what it is that I really
want to learn so I go backwards then we
go do some more work then we start
talking about domain driven design and I
don't well I might show them the whole
mind map just to say just so you know
boom you know this is what it this is
what DDD is right we're not going to
worry about it but you know just be
aware and I make sure they understand
about strategic design and also tactical
design so I give them the big picture
and then but big picture overview E
stuff and then we go back and we focus
on something that they can do and they
can work on right and and you know
another another client the
client that I worked with recently again
so they were about a year into the
project and so it was a very different
kind of engagement it wasn't this whole
idea of the Legacy Project so we I
actually spent the first two days
listening to them argue right and the
architect apologize deeply for that but
actually I told him it was really
valuable because it helped me understand
all the perspectives of the issues that
were going on so I could figure out a
nice way to help help them with things
and then we did start looking at their
code and we did start you know like I
talked a little bit about value objects
for example and then we looked at their
code and said hmm you know all right
what here do you think would make a good
value object and we kind of did some mob
programming and hammered on that and all
in all you know for me it's about
opening the gate right like there's all
this beautiful stuff here I'm just
trying to open the gate and make it
accessible and appealing right I make
sure people understand and this actually
when I'm working with the legacy systems
I'm also quite often working with people
my age who have been you know doing
database driven stuff for a long time or
really focused on you know really
they're kind of the way they've been
thinking about their domain has been the
same for 20 years and it's really really
hard for them to shift so for me to say
hey I have been there and done that and
I have to say this completely changed
the way I approach building software now
it's huge right so maybe somebody to
call me a zealot who knows but but for
it for I think a different reason so
this is this is just a quick look at at
the path that I do when I'm teaching DDD
so I talk about for example the people
who focus on database I try to explain
that database persistence is really a
cross-cutting concern it's you know
unless you're building the next Dropbox
right this isn't your core domain
focus on on domain you know what is the
domain what are the problems you're
solving try to help people understand
that one of the big goals why do we even
do all this is because DDD really helps
take big messy problems that are like a
big bowl of spaghetti and helps us
organizing it away and break things down
into small problems that we can really
solve it's so much easier to solve a
small problem then a big tangled mess of
problems right just find this thing you
can identify and focus on I talked about
how important strategic not just how
important strategic design is but make
sure people really understand even if
I'm so often focusing on tactical design
making sure people really understand
strategic design is you know just as
important as the tactical it's you know
it's there make sure they understand
that's really key even if we're not
focused on it yet anyway so I just try
to walk them through you know a lot of
high-level stuff and what I think are
the four from my perspective the things
that really helped me find my entry
points into DDD that I was really
benefiting from in the beginning now
there are people who have definitely
responded to this approach of teaching
DDD and helping people understand it by
just doing you know a little bit or
let's just focus on you know let's the
aggregate roots it's a great idea from
dhih dhih dhih dhih dhih dhih dhih and
it also is something that we can
implement even if we're not using or
thinking about the rest of DDD right
like why not and and you know maybe
somebody will call that DDD light I
don't care right it doesn't bother me at
all it's still the whole point is we're
taking advantage of these great ideas
right away immediately and benefiting
from them even if we're not ready to do
the whole big picture so just to make
sure
I've done what I think is a really
important message also whenever I talk
about DDD is make sure I talk about
strategic and tactical so people
understand especially because people
look at me and they see they go oh
entity framework data persistence right
and that's very tactical like that that
part of DDD domain modelling and
aggregates and the value objects and all
that stuff so strategic is really really
important because that's where we're
defining you know talking about how
important the client collaboration is
right figuring out what your core domain
is and really getting a laser focus on
that how important the strategic design
is to reducing the stress and reducing
the complexity of the problems that
you've got and the bounded context and
that ubiquitous language actually
defining that language the language that
describes the particular context that
you're working in the language that you
use while you're talking about it with
other people whether it's business
owners or developers or people who are
building various different perspectives
on on the team and even into the code
right that ubiquitous language for a
particular context all the way through
and then tactical I think that the
really important things about the
tactical design is it helps me write
much better code right the value objects
understanding how important one-way
navigations are right people don't
really think about that we always think
of because there's two points in a
relationship you always have to navigate
in both ways and how important a lot of
these patterns are to eliminate some of
the side effects that you might have as
you know that's a perfect example having
a navigation that you never use but you
always have to worry about honoring it
when when you're coding and then the
last thing I just want to leave you with
is when I was with this client that had
the you know I don't talk to me about
DDD anymore the CTO actually is a huge
company CTO asked me you know so how
does one help
somebody get started with domain-driven
design and I just off the top my head
gave him some ideas and I thought I
would capsulate them so first first the
strategic part of domain driven design
events storming is really really amazing
it's a great way to help especially
higher level business people understand
the beauty of it because one of the
outcomes of event storming and event
storming is like brainstorming with
sticky notes and you bring in all kinds
of you bring in people from all across
the business who understand so you know
business owners product owners coders
that you know some the database people
the finance people etc bring bringing
all of them in so the one of the
outcomes of that is getting down to
bounded context and understanding
domains and a lot of times what happens
is people go whoa right I never really
understood our business in this way this
is amazing so that's been really helpful
and even if you're not doing you know
true events storming just brainstorming
right like just doing some discovery
about about your domains and about your
business if you're focused on the
tactical and I think pear or mob
programming is really important
especially if there's somebody who has a
better understanding of some of the
principles from tactical design and you
know sit down and do some refactoring
and capsulate methods because that helps
get you towards an understanding of
aggregate roots right aggregate roots
you know are all about control and
making sure that your aggregate keeps
responsive the route keeps
responsibility for what's going on in
there
identify some of these one-to-one
relationships that exist in your system
and do some brainstorming around hey
which one of these should be value
objects probably 95 percent of them it
turns out and also you know with the
two-way navigations look for some of
those and see if you can eliminate one
of the navigations
you're not really using anyway and you
know and see what kind of side effects
that that eliminates so these are some
of the first steps as opposed to well
the first thing you should do is you
know get the blue book or one of the
other DVD books and just sit and read it
end to end and now we're gonna do all
DDD right so I think just getting
started with some of these smaller tasks
is a great way to get somebody excited
about the benefits of domain-driven
design just by having success by one of
these things right by learning how to do
the one don't worry the lines will all
be gone by the time you get down there
so that's really what I wanted to share
with you and for me the most important
part of it is to be able to invite other
people in to benefiting from
domain-driven design instead of getting
so focused on the whole big picture that
whole mind map all of those turn all the
terminology all of the rules right
because I think that really shuts a lot
of people out and so they're not getting
those benefits that I've certainly
realized and I know that when people
really come to these aha moments it's
it's really really amazing so I hope
that helps you with your DDD journey and
also if you're sharing your DDD journey
with other people on your team and your
company or other developers in your
community so thank you very much I
really appreciate this time to be able
to talk about this and I hope that it
was helpful for you thanks
[Applause]